hey guys
hi uh thanks for taking the time today
um i wanted to start off by asking
one of the things uh i really like about
the documentary is it shows how sparks
forges their own path has you know kind
of they're always their own direction
but i was curious
what was your relationship like with the
record labels and companies that
may not have always been thrilled that
you weren't chasing trends
well we were really fortunate i think
the the one of the few advantages of
being at this stage of our career was
that
when we started the the record companies
were
a little bit more enlightened and that
they felt that
even if we weren't selling an enormous
amount of records
that that kind of what we were giving to
the label as a balance to
other artists was was a kind of
enriching what the label represented
that
we had the first two albums out in the
states that
that you know with todd runkin and
bearsville where
they didn't sell an enormous amount but
but warner brothers who would kind of
own
was a part of bearsville they they
really
appreciated what we could bring to to
the label even if it wasn't
selling a lot of records and then later
on we
we were lucky enough to be involved with
island records in the
70s where chris blackwell was really
an enlightened kind of person in the
visionary so
we're fortunate just that that the
things that have happened for us didn't
need to happen
within two or three days or else you're
gone
that there were people that would stick
with what we were doing
knowing that in time that there there
would be kind of
acceptance of it and i i don't think
that exists now and i
i feel bad for for bands now that are in
that
position where it's kind of do or die
within a very short amount of time
so many uh artists show up in this film
and they talk about
how much sparks meant to them and how
they were inspired by sparks and pulled
from sparks
four sparks i'm curious who are your
inspirations who are the artists that
you admire
well early on we we were huge
anglophiles
and so when we were growing up and it's
it's talked about
to a large extent in the documentary um
you know we we returned to the uk and
sitting here in l.a kind of going
against the grain of
of the laurel canyon kind of vibe that
was
also prevalent here at that time but we
always
loved the english bands that early on
like the early who the early kinks and
the
move and obviously the beetles and the
stones
yes we felt there was there was kind of
a certain
um bigger than life quality is how we
perceive
them that they they they look different
than us
they they acted different on stage it
was more of a show
that they were putting on at that at
that point and the
lyrics to some of those bands we
mentioned were kind of
really special and unique and seemed a
bit exotic
to us to being from la and hearing songs
about waterloo sunset and what's
waterloo
and and you know all of that village
greens
and tattoos you know the who's singing
of tattoos and like a
small a small kind of subject matter but
made into kind of a a bigger topic
because it's being addressed in a song
so all those things kind of intrigued us
and so we always kind of gravitated more
to the uk during the
the our more formative years of
of music how did you prepare
for directing your first documentary is
it a different tool set
than directing a narrative feature yeah
i guess the
the obvious difference is like you're
making a movie you're starting a story
from scratch
and like nobody knows what the story is
so you kind of like have the chance to
sort of
develop it as you go along but with this
is like you're taking like sort of
an existing story and figuring out how
to make it into a film
and so i mean if anything it was kind of
just there's like
an embarrassment of riches and i think
also because
part of my pitch to ronald russell was
that i wanted to tell the whole story
i didn't want to be like one of these
documentaries that you get well because
sparks are an unusual case because
they're a band that are sort of
bringing out music regularly by every
two or three years
and most other bands that started at the
same time have sort of either
become like a their own tribute act or
not releasing music or even when they do
it sort of they release it always feels
like kind of
pleasing the audience are writing pop
songs it's beneath them
so what sparks were doing to me was just
incredible and i felt like
it would be my thesis was basically to
say
like the 70s is not the golden period
the golden period is like 50 years long
like we're still in the golden period of
sparks so that was basically my thesis
and
and and so in terms of telling the story
it was about like
um looking at the archive obviously
and finding archives of things that we
knew existed but
like we had to kind of like get hold of
them and then it was
really i i thought i would create an
oral history because
obviously incredible to interview ronald
russell
and then you know but also to bring in
how they have touched other people's
lives
is to talk to fans famous
and non-famous you know and have like
that equilibrium so
there's there's no is a an equivalence
between
john taylor from duran duran and like
julia marcus who
stage invaded age 12 and sort of
what anybody has to say about sparks
whatever like experience level
or whatever knowledge is valid and so
that to me was important because it was
something to sort of show
the massive cultural footprint of sparks
then it needed to be a proper oral
history and in that sense i ended up
interviewing 80 people
and and that was that was amazing
because it just felt to me that that
the influence is so big that
you know just having three or four
interview interviews didn't seem quite
right
and also you know because you could show
it wasn't just like it was
one period that was influential it's
like five periods
and you can sort of see you know like
the sort of the fans that come into the
story throughout
you know i wasn't there at the start but
i came in at a certain point and and
never let go
and other people did the same do you
feel that this is a documentary you'll
have to keep updating i mean we have
annette coming out later this year and
i'm super excited for that or is this
sort of
do you feel like there's a good end
point for this story
this is the first 50 years and then
there's gonna be a part two and three so
it's
eventually it's gonna cover 150 years of
the sparks
it's going to be like my my collapse at
7up
[Laughter]
we've already we've signed on as part of
the contract too
so yeah it's a three picture deal three
picture
documentary deal the third one they
go into space with jeff basil
[Laughter]
so for you know someone looking to get
into sparks
this is a question for all three of you
would you recommend starting with the
documentary or do you think it would be
better to start
with a particular album or a particular
era
well i have this theory because i get
asked this a lot is what album should i
start with and the truth is
it's difficult to sum up sparks in one
album
because okay you could say commander my
house a classic album
but it's not the whole story so i sort
of sometimes got it down to like five i
mean
ultimately you know like there's more
than one great
best of and in fact there'll be a
soundtrack album for this film which is
a
pretty good like journey through the
decades as you could as you could want
but when i try and pin it down to
like five albums and and these can
change because there's so many there's
more than five great albums
like come on in my house number
next to my pants then i'm jumping
a lot already but um and hippopotamus
that's
that at least starts to get the sense of
the shape but obviously there's
even more than that so it is like that's
why i decided to
sort of document the entire discography
is i i'd heard from people who even were
aware of sparks that they said oh
i want to get into sparks i'm so daunted
by the discography so
it was great to do a documentary where
you could do an overview of the entire
career
and also it was important to do every
album because
a lot of music documentaries don't
they'll gloss over like
a flop like the bg's documentary which
was great i
really loved it but the only my only
criticism
was like oh i wanted to hear about the
sergeant pepper film
and obviously that thing gets skipped
over like skip over those two years
but with this it was like in a weird way
the the
the albums that maybe didn't sell well
at the time
they go on to be influential in their
own way so
eventually like no album is
more or less important than another one
thank you guys so much
i thought the documentary was fantastic
and just congratulations on everything
thank you thank you